thank you and welcome welcome to this
gorgeous hall and what a joy it is to be
with you in person and to those who are
watching welcome as well um
i want to say first of all should you
tweet
iq2 is your hashtag for the evening um
you are well aware we're here to debate
the proposal we were right
to brexit
i know how personally many people took
the referendum and the months and years
after that i think it's probably worth
before we start bearing in mind the
words of the queen at the end of the
jubilee where she praised the kindness
joy and kinship that she felt had sprung
up and said that she hoped that the
sense of togetherness her own phrase
would last beyond the event let's
certainly hope it can last
beyond this debate
in the knowledge that we all need to
leave the same hall and go into our
small very beautiful and often very damp
island and live together um i should
make one full point of disclosure um i
have no dan socially we've met a couple
of times
dominic grieve i waved at once in
central london he did not wave back to
me
a social and professional snub that will
cause him great suffering in the evening
to come
before we start we're going to ask you
to submit your pre-vote to get an idea
of where your opinions lie and of course
to see if our speakers managed to change
your opinion at all if you haven't done
so um you can hold up your phones and
scan the qr code behind me or use the
link that you received before the event
please vote for the motion against the
notion or if you are unsure
undecided if you're watching on the live
stream just click on the polls button to
vote we'll announce the pre-vote results
after we've heard the opening speeches
um
we have a lovely panel here a
fascinating panel and a high profile
panel um and i'm not going to run
through all of their biographies you
probably know them and we'll introduce
them one by one the format of the
evening is relatively simple each
speaker will address you for
nine minutes um i will do
that it was terrible sorry i'll try and
make more noise at eight minutes and
they'll need to wrap at nine we will
then um put a couple of points back and
forth to them we'll announce the
pre-vote and then we'll move to
questions um and i'll probably repeat
this but it is questions rather than
statements points to be made to our
speakers rather than points you are
making to the rest of the audience if
you can work out my fine delineation
there let's move straight to the debate
um the first speaker who is in favor of
the motion is lord hannan daniel hannon
former conservative member of the
european parliament for southeast
england of course a prominent and very
positive campaigner for brexit one of
the very few who went on and made the
case
for the sunlit uplands that were going
to emerge may yet emerge out of brexit
and he has nine minutes dan
well johnny thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen thank you all for coming
i'm conscious that this is something of
an away fixture this is not just
a london crowd but a cool part of camden
so this is you know this is manchester
city at old trafford as it were this is
this is everton uh at anfield or uh or
ian botham doing a tour of pakistan
or or rishi sunak coming to boris's
birthday party this is uh no then the
king commanded and they brought daniel
and cast him into the den of lions i i
want to start by
echoing the point that johnny just made
or rather that he
as the bbc's royal correspondent echoed
from the queen's majesty about
togetherness i'll tell you my single
biggest regret
about the referendum and its aftermath
was the polarization and the nastiness
that followed
which i have to say i don't remember
from the campaign itself i was out
manning street stalls campaigning almost
every day and very often we would run
into campaigners from the other side in
their blue stronger in t-shirts and we'd
pose for selfies together and we'd wish
each other luck
and it was still a fairly civil and
civilized conversation i remember
speaking from this very stage about a
week before the vote uh with adam
zamoyski and the late roger scrutin
among others and it was a a a an
edifying disagreement about trade and
tariffs and sovereignty and money and
all the rest of it
the the the way in which both sides went
into purity spirals and made this about
identity and about what kind of people
they imagined
on the other side i think is my single
biggest regret
and so i don't want to add to the
polarization tonight so let me begin
by making what i hope would be in normal
circumstances a completely
uncontroversial point which is that
whatever decision we'd made
in june 2016 there were going to be
positive and negative outcomes
there were risks and gains we're staying
in there were risks and gains with
leaving
let me
add that not everyone will have got the
version they wanted i was uh as some of
you will know i was a i was an afterman
all the way through i thought we should
have gone for a swiss type deal i think
it would have saved us a lot of trouble
to have gone for an off-the-shelf
deal i didn't get exactly what i wanted
neither will robert have done neither
will boris have done right because all
of these things are compromises so i'm
not going to try and argue here that
everything is perfect but perfection is
not for this
sublunary world
but i am going to argue
that it is better on balance than the
alternative would have been
first of all let me make the point that
the
predictions of disaster that were made
not just by campaigners which is fair
enough both sides are obviously going to
put their best gloss on things but were
made by the official bodies the bank of
england the chancellor of the exchequer
the treasury imf the oecd
spectacularly failed to materialize
we were told that if we voted leave the
stock exchange would immediately
collapse it carried on rising we were
told that if we voted leave unemployment
would surge
it fell and fell and fell fell to its
lowest level uh prior to the coronavirus
there were more people in work than ever
before in british history we were told
that house prices would collapse they
rose we were told that there would be
disinvestment there would be this
massive recession again this was this
was not the remain campaign saying this
we were told by the treasury that there
would be a recession in 2016 stretching
into 2017
that emphatically did not happen in fact
you know we can argue the toss about
whether it would have been even better
had we stayed in or whatever and you
know
necessarily we're dealing with
alternative histories there but the one
thing which i want to to say i think
fairly uncontroversially is that it was
not catastrophic and that the evidence
of that
is that prior to the uh coronavirus the
uk economy had outgrown the eurozone
economy so whether it might have been
even better or whatever look you'll all
have your own views but the
the prediction of an absolute calamity
failed to materialize as by the way did
the various predictions of non-economic
calamities
we were told that if we voted to leave
scotland would immediately leave the
union in fact support for the united
kingdom according to the opinion polls
rose in scotland after the vote
we were told that if we voted to leave
there would be refugee camps in kent
that all of the the the sort of
refugee
infrastructure would move in some
unspecified way
to to british soil of course that didn't
happen and in fact we were told that if
we voted leave that the country would
become
more closed to migration
that has emphatically not happened if
you look at the numbers of visas in any
category given this year
they are higher than pre-referendum
higher
than pre-brexit whether you're looking
at work visas student visas family
unification we have become
a much more
global country and with the bonus
that as
levels of immigration have risen
concern about immigration has fallen
because people are prepared to
to sustain a
quite a large degree of immigration
provided they know that it is legal and
controlled uh rather than out of their
hands which was of course what we argued
at the time finally we were told that we
wouldn't get any trade deals and i have
to say that this country has signed more
trade deals in a shorter time
than any other country i think ever
it's true a lot of those replicate where
we were with the eu but that was done
and we've now moved on to the others
we're about to join the trans-pacific
partnership a huge growing block
representing nearly a third of the
world's gdp we are likely this year to
become the first western country to have
a serious fta or an fda of any kind with
india and of course we've already got
our deals with australia new zealand
we're pushing ahead with south america
the gulf and other places
i also think we've passed the two big
tests
one foreign and one domestic as an
independent country the first foreign
test was of course the war in ukraine
we were in the front line defending
european values we started earlier and
we stuck at it harder
we were not under any threat from russia
there was no scenario in which russian
troops were going to be marching through
kent
but as in 1914
as in 1939 we took our responsibility
seriously as a defender of european
civilization
and not only did we leave the defense of
ukraine the supply of weapons but we
were the first country to lift all of
our tariffs and restrictions on
ukrainian exports i'm glad to say the eu
followed a few weeks later now of course
you could say well that we could have
done all of those things in the eu
realistically i don't think anyone in
brussels is actually arguing that that
would have happened we've set the
the moral tone and our neighbors
followed
and then of course the first great
national test was how to respond uh to
the virus and we had we effectively won
the vaccine race twice first uh with the
first jab uh
in the world and the the quickest
vaccine roll out and then with the
quickest booster round and again you
might say well technically we could have
still done that uh if we were in the u
come on look at what almost every
remainer was arguing at the time that we
had to go into the eu vaccination
procurement scheme that we were going to
be killing people if we didn't do it
even as a non-member we had to go along
with what they were doing does anyone
seriously imagine
i'm i'm sure neither dominic nor stella
will be
shifty enough to try and argue this that
we would had we been a full member that
we would have been able to resist that
pressure so i think we have passed with
flying colors but i have to finish on
this point
the eu
let's recall this is the only actor to
have put
however briefly to have invoked a border
in ireland for the sole purpose of
preventing
vaccines reaching the united kingdom
and what i infer from that is that
although we are trying to be good
neighbours although we recognize that we
want the eu to prosper just as we wanted
to be secure we wanted to be rich we
want them to be wealthy neighbors so
that they're good customers and we like
them
they have still not got over the idea
that britain is a recalcitrant province
that needs to be taught a lesson and
brought to heal
ultimately i would rather live in a
generous open global country interested
and engaged in the affairs of every
continent including europe than in one
that cannot get over its relations with
its biggest market and closest neighbor
and that's why i am happy to live in a
global britain prosperous
independent and free
thank you thank you very much dan
uh let's hear our first speaker against
motion it is of course dominic grieve qc
who was the mp conservative mp for
beckensfield former
uh shadow home secretary attorney
general as well and expelled from the
party um in the astonishing
constitutional contortions of late 2019.
dominic thank you
[Applause]
it's always a pleasure to have a
discussion with dan
whether it's on uh brexit europe or
anything else his politeness is
legendary
and uh i have to say it makes a change
from being called a french streter or
other vile epithets which on occasion
have been directed my way but i have to
say that before coming here this evening
my wife who is pure yorkshire
said to me all you have to do
is just go along and tell them in plain
anglo-saxon how it is
i couldn't disagree more with dan
the evidence 18 months after we've come
out of transition
is that this is the biggest mistake in
modern british history
making massive
self-inflicted wounds on our body
politic and our unity
damaging to our economic well-being
our security and indeed our sovereign
power of influence in the world
now it may all have been done for very
good reasons and i don't doubt dan's
sincerity for one bit
just before the referendum he wrote a
tremendous blog on ian martin's reaction
piece
and which interesting ian martin has
written an article today expressing some
misgivings about brexit
and he said this it's 24th of june 2025
and britain is marking its annual
independence day celebration as the
fireworks streams through the summer sky
still not quite dark we wonder why it
took us so long to leave
the years that followed the 2016
referendum didn't just reinvigorate our
economy our democracy and our liberty
they improve relations with our
neighbors
the united kingdom is now the region's
foremost knowledge-based economy and so
on
well we're only three
years away from that magical date
and the evidence
is entirely to the country
we know
that the office of budget responsibility
government quango in a sense but
independent
has told us
that the reduction in our gdp
is going to be in the long term four
percent as a consequence of brexit
unless of course it's made up elsewhere
seven out of ten exporters
called by the british chamber of
commerce just recently
have said they have put it been put at a
severe competitive disadvantage
and the food and drinks
organization has pointed out from its
members
that their exports are down
23.7 percent on those of 2019
there are massive costs to what we've
done
the government is going to need a time
when it says it wants to get rid of
civil servants 50 000 customs officials
to deal with our own
customs checks as and when we decide to
bring them in
and that requires
205 million customs declarations a year
costing between 15 and 55 pounds each
for every business and individual who
has to do it
and where are the compensations
dan you spoke about these foreign trade
agreements
but apart from the rolled over
agreements we could have had with the eu
we haven't got them
the united states is much keener to do a
trade deal with the eu than it is with
us the idea of a trade deal with china
is for the birds and i have to say i
think a trade deal with india is rather
unlikely
and this wonderful trade deal with
australia the government's own figures
is it will
reduce the cost of food products by one
pound a year per household
0.002
addition to our economy over 15 years
our financial sector
is suffering enormously this is 80
of our gdp now dan in his great paper
his polemic
told us
this wonderful thing financial services
this is 2025 vision are booming not only
in london but in birmingham leeds and
edinburgh too
after britain left the eu's regulations
became even more heavy-handed driving
more exiles from paris frankfurt and
milan to us
no other european city could hope to
compete
well we've lost 7 000 jobs from the
financial sector in london that's the
current position
and in addition to that
400
financial firms have moved uh
which do euro
dealing
have shifted off about 1.5 trillion of
assets
one firm has pointed out aqueous that
99.6 of its european share dealing is
now done from paris and remember this
isn't just abstracts
because all this is about
ultimately tax revenue for the
government
which it loses
so i find it very difficult amsterdam
has overtaken us as the leading trading
venue for share trading
so where's the future that was promised
with that
now perhaps with deregulation but i have
to say i'm not sure we're going to get
it
because actually deregulating on your
own unless you do it in company with
others is in practice impossible
and immigration well we're very short of
people to work in this country
i know 500 000 power
000 people short in september 2021 to
provide basic services it's one of the
reasons why unemployment's so low but
instead of a flexible mechanism by which
people could come here and work and go
home we have a much less flexible
mechanism which then requires us to deal
with hundreds of thousands of visa
applications i really wonder if the
public
suddenly decided that as long as it's a
visa application they're happy with it
but if it isn't they're not
the truth with that
is that this suggestion that was made at
the time has absolutely no validity to
it
now
leveling up
leveling up agenda is about pumping
money into places which need leveling up
well all i can say is that whereas we
were pumping in 4.5 billion pounds of eu
money before we left which the
government promised it would replace as
part of its leveling up agenda
actually the maximum they can afford at
the moment is 2.6 billion per anna
so how does that help the prime
minister's aspirations
and i turn to influence because i think
it really does matter
because i'm old-fashioned conservative i
understand about influence and i'm very
proud of my country
but i have to say it absolutely beats me
how brexit makes us more influential i
spent my time as chairman of the isc
between 2016 and 2019 being visited by
foreign delegations from countries
outside of europe saying britain's role
in our area is weakening
you are over-obsessed with your domestic
problems you're not looking at us and
we're looking elsewhere for friendly
influence
even with the ukraine
ultimately i'm very proud of what we're
doing in ukraine for the ukraine
very much in favor of it but i simply
say this
france and germany are the lead
countries on the policy of the eu
towards the ukraine and the eu is
divided on policy towards the ukraine
does britain have more influence over
that in or out of the eu
that's ultimately where the key
decisions will be made along with the
united states
and as divisions appear that's where the
problems will come from and our ability
to influence those is reduced and our
behavior of the northern ireland
protocol which highlights so completely
the problem that we have in bringing a
proper brexit about is going to damage
our ability to do that still further
and that brings me to my final point i
can't escape the fact that on monday 148
of my former colleagues in parliament
voted to get rid of the prime minister
and they did it because he was dishonest
and because he's a charlatan
and because he's doing great damage to
this country
but he isn't there by accident
he got there dan
because in the middle of the inability
to deliver a sensible brexit
by proper means
people turned to somebody who would do
it by
fraud and that
is
what is now haunting our country's
politics
and our well-being and i have to say
it's a direct consequence of what we did
in 2016.
dominic thank you
dominique thank you very much
um
ended only four seconds over you were
very very disciplined thank you i'm our
third speaker tonight arguing in favor
of the motion is professor robert toombs
historian of france and britain fellow
of st john's college cambridge whose
most recent book is this sovereign isle
britain in and out of europe robert
thank you
thanks very much it's good to be here
and a rather younger audience than i
expected often it's rather middle-aged
people come to these things i'm glad to
see that you're not so i think that
probably means you're more uh
shall i say favoring the other side than
you are favoring our side
um
i had some qualms about leaving the eu
back in 2016. i was subject to project
fear like most people were
i wasn't sure how it would work and i
certainly hesitated about
voting i eventually voted leave since
then i got involved
more actively i certainly was not
actively involved in the campaign before
because it seemed to me that the the the
vote had to be carried out
and uh
i'm rather
being rather proud that the that i
helped to form a group called briefings
for brexit
which uh had the signal honour of
recently have been hacked by the
russians
so we so we must be doing something
right they accuse us of of um plotting
against the state anyway
but that's not the reason why i
was in favor and am in favor
of having left the eu i think big
reasons for doing so are the same now as
they were in 2016.
and i guess i'm a bit of an idealist on
this matter because i think of it more
in terms of europe
the debate or the discussion that takes
place in this country is almost entirely
about us it's an amazingly insular one i
don't think mr grieve once mentioned
europe as an entity as a as an
institution
and that's what i'm going to do because
that's what i think it's really ought to
be about
the eu is first of all damaging to
democracy it's an undemocratic
indeed a consciously and deliberately
anti-democratic institution it's run by
a rather corrupt
elite which despises opposition
it's it's one aspect of what political
scientists call the withdrawal of elites
they withdraw into institutions so
they're no longer accountable to their
voters
the eu is run in secret and not
surprisingly less than a quarter of the
people of europe feel that they
understand how it works that's natural
because that's how it's meant to be
if you were annoyed about illegal
consumption of birthday cake
which i'm sure many of you were you must
be incandescent at what the leaders of
the eu get up to christine lagarde
chair of the european central bank was
found guilty of complicity in
malvestation of 400 million euros of
public funds
the present president of the commission
ursula van der lion
was found in 2016 to have
plagiarized her ph.d dissertation
the man who represents europe to the
world joseph bohel had to resign his
position as chair of the european uh
university institute because he kept
secret the fact that he was being paid
300 000 a year by a spanish energy
company those are the sorts of people
who who run the eu
if it was a brilliant success
we might
might put up with this but it's a
failure too in its fundamental aims of
peace and prosperity it's impoverished a
large part of europe through the euro
system 20 of the eu's member states
actually saw their growth rates fall
after they joined
[Music]
there's been a popular decline in
support continuously since the 1990s
in france which is the country most
similar to us among european member
states
only about
only about a third of the people say
they trust the eu
the world's changing europe's becoming
less important economically and
politically we may lament this but it's
a fact
the 20th century was continental
the 21st century will be oceanic that
will be the theater of power of
geopolitics of commerce who said that
emmanuel macron
the economic importance of the eu to
britain has been declining continuously
for decades it's still worth about 13 of
gdp but this is mainly trade with four
or five eu countries so most of the eu
is in fact pretty irrelevant to us we
have a huge deficit in trade with the eu
though it's actually improved since we
left
and we have a surplus with the rest of
the world so it's clearly advantageous
for us to diversify or to continue to
diversify our trading relations and to
encourage this by the sort of trading
policies that dan hannon referred to
the growth in our exports to the eu have
been increasing by 0.5 percent
a year
since
the early 2000s
six times faster have been our exports
to the rest of the world that's where
our future interest lies
those are the reasons for voting in 2016
but there are new reasons since i would
say and daniel
has
mentioned some of them so i won't go
over them again
the covid crisis
yes we could have produced vaccines
inside the eu but when the government
decided not to it was it was roundly
criticized by the opposition
it seems to be very unlikely that we
would have
developed our vaccines without having
members of the eu less than one tenth of
the people of europe are happy with the
way the eu handled the kovid epidemic
the eu has proved divided and weak at
best over ukraine
we are much more decisive and principled
i'm glad to say and i find it very
difficult to believe that our sovereign
power of influence as mr grieve put it
has declined
the eu has proved antagonistic and rigid
in its dealings with us which i admit
took me and many others by surprise
david frost said it surprised him i'm
sure it surprised theresa may i thought
we could expect
a friendly
desire for good relations from our
european friends and partners but the
determination of the eu to punish brexit
is unmistakable and indeed unconcealed
the eu wants to keep britain as the
captive market for its exports
unable to compete freely and as a sort
of political satellite too a plan which
was recently revived again by by macron
for all these reasons the eu has
exploited the ireland situation in a
reckless manner risking political
instability and summary refusing every
proposal to solve the problem
practically
its representatives have frequently used
provocative language and tried to
interfere in internal politics
admittedly with the encouragement of
some remainer politicians
almost as unforgivable with the shameful
attacks on the astrazeneca vaccine by
america macro and the eu
and one could also mention crude threats
over fishing
so of course one might conclude that we
should regret leaving the eu or
contemplate rejoining because they're a
nasty a lot than we realized but that's
not a course i favor
and finally project fear has proved
empty it was fear that motivated most of
the remain vote two-thirds said that
they voted mostly out of economic worry
or fear of isolation and i was nearly
one of those
a million fewer jobs said the cbi 8
million job losses said remainer mp
heidi allen an emergency budget and tax
rises said george osborne a recession
half a million job losses falling wages
said the treasury
by the way it's the treasury figures
that are still being quoted by the obr
which mr grieve referred to although
they've been wholly discredited
in fact
after the 2016 vote the economy grew
faster than the eurozone unemployment
fell and wages rose
so all these fears have proved unfounded
although there's a constant attempt to
keep project fear alive by blaming every
setback on brexit
automatically siding with the eu against
the british government on every occasion
irrespective of the facts
now what is the real economic situation
now sorry is that one minute or is that
the end ah okay
food prices are going up
the fault of brexit well they're going
up more in the euro zone
gdp growth is higher in the euro zone
and it was in 21 2021 2022
we have had a fall in our exports to the
eu but they're mainly due to oil uh
because we don't produce as much and we
don't sell as much as we used to but in
goods there's been no fall in our
exports to the eu and as i said earlier
our net trading position that's to say
the comparison of exports and imports to
and from the eu has actually improved
since 2016.
for many of our leading companies over
60 of their trade is now outside the eu
but but i'll stop there um conclusion
brexit i think was a rejection of
pessimism and declinism the idea that we
were not capable of governing ourselves
we were too weak to exist as a as a
separate and independent nation
and it was an endorsement of national
democracy and for that reason alone we
were right to brexit
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much robert i should say
when one speaker is up the other two
speakers huddle like this i'm training
to hear what they have to say to each
other but we will hear it out loud our
final speaker making the case against
the motion is stella creasy labour mp
for walthamstow since 2010 and chair of
the labour movement for europe stella
it's always marvelous when your mother's
in the audience
did anybody notice that both the
speakers for the proposition got their
defense in early suggested that you
wouldn't be open-minded on this that you
probably had already
made up your mind i wonder what it is
ladies and gentlemen that makes them not
be confident in the case they want to
make this evening
and i think it's something rather simple
it's that i'm not sure we've actually
had the brexit that they promised us
i think we might have had brexit in name
only so let's look at the actual
evidence of this and i talk about brexit
since it actually happened not 2016 but
actually when we did leave the single
market and join this wonderful
free trade agreement because all the
evidence suggests that we have all the
economic and social hit
of leaving the european union but none
of the freedoms and benefits that were
promised no one least of all daniel i
know can be happy with that
daniel i think of rather affectionately
as the kaiser soze of brexit you didn't
see him coming but we've all seen the
consequences to be fair to daniel he
wasn't one of those people promising us
that net migration would be under a
hundred thousand a year that was michael
gove it is now 239 000 a year he didn't
drive a bus with 350 million for the nhs
written on the back of it too far the
nhs has had more money that's down to
the pandemic not brexit and he didn't
say we would take back control of our
fish
but the new research showing this year
that significant eu access to the waters
around the uk remain indeed to those of
six to 12 nautical miles that we were
promised would be ours and ours alone
and in fact the evidence shows us that
since we left the european union
the brexit trade deal means that
exporting fish and seafood costs more
and takes longer so the fish is less
fresh and the customers have been lost
so perhaps have more chips and less fish
with your national disk thanks to brexit
daniel did say we could do better than
being part of this regional association
he calls it largest trading bloc in the
world to everybody else but no matter
geography wasn't important to him the uk
is yet to implement though since we left
the european union a single brand new
trade deal that it couldn't have had
under the existing terms of the european
union even in our relationship with
japan indeed the only point of
contention about the new trade deal with
japan is whether we are worse off than
we would have been if we'd stayed in the
european union
daniel didn't argue that we would need
to leave the single market but has now
argued that we should never have left
but it would be mad to go back it's a
bit like being locked out of your house
but then saying it's madness to go and
see a locksmith and get some keys cut so
that you can actually
get back in so this this brexit that
nobody will take responsibility for what
has it given us well as ian martin that
well-known ramona has told us exports to
the eu i'm sorry to report robin robert
rather are down almost 12 percent
that's not an insubstantial figure
indeed the uk in a changing europe's
research an independent body shows that
brexit has predicted 25
fall in imports
why does that matter because the fallen
imports isn't just about whether you can
eat french brie or have
a german sausage it's actually about the
money and the impact that you have on
our production lines two-thirds of
international trade is products that we
use as inputs in our chains of
production and supply chain
what does that mean in practice for all
of us it means it's much harder for our
businesses to make do little wonder that
eu uk trade relationships are down 33
and it is mainly small businesses we
might be a nation of shopkeepers but
many are shutting up shop as a result of
brexit indeed it has affected the cost
of living the biggest crisis that we now
face post-pandemic the increase in those
trade barriers has led to a six percent
increase in food prices again not my
words the uk and are changing europe
independent research inflation and food
products that britain tends to import
from the european union like fresh pork
tomatoes and jams was much more
pronounced than that tuna or exotic
fruit so basically ladies and gentlemen
you're left with a hawaiian pizza and
not much else
because you cannot eat red tape but
you've got an awful lot more of it as a
result of brexit and that is a hit not
just for trade but also for our tax take
because the obr again an independent
body i'm sorry to disappoint you rob it
shows that economic growth is down four
percent as a result of these trends and
every one percent of loss of growth is a
nine billion pound loss of revenue for
the nhs for social care for our policing
but what about those regulatory freedoms
we were promised surely surely those are
those sunny uplift lands
well the reality shows us that since
we've left the european union very
little has changed and it's not hard to
see why the divergence tracker shows us
that for all those freedoms that were
hard fought by people like daniel and
robert there are only 27 cases of actual
divergence from those thousands of
restrictive rules that the eu brought us
in let's have a look at what some of
those might be those benefits that you
are voting for if you vote yes tonight
well they do include trophy hunting but
not fogar and fur because of course
nothing is too good for the workers um
it is about compensation on flights uh
the government is using divergence to
make sure that you don't get as much
compensation if your flight is delayed
if you are sat at gatwick in the coming
weeks do think about that one as a
benefit of brexit um also
non-recognition of blue badges for
disabled people again a point of
divergence that the government has yet
to do anything about for those 2.3
million of people for whom a blue badge
is a critical way of moving around the
country
as again uk and changing europe point
out the benefits of brexit document the
government produced all 105 pages was
not short of ideas but many of those
ideas were things that you could have
done in the european union anyway and
most are recycled and possibly asking
readers of the sun as jacob rees-mogg
has now done to come up with ideas isn't
the best use of those few civil servants
that have actually come into the
office's time
because the truth is any radical
divergence is unlikely to be possible
because what it does to businesses ask
them to choose it asks them to choose
whether they would only trade in the uk
or whether they would only trade with
europe or whether they want to run two
separate regulatory regimes and with an
audience nearby of 600 million customers
it's not hard to see why business is
calling for the government not to be
radical and indeed there are some
regulations you probably do want to keep
for good reason for example right now
the government is having to reconfigure
our airline safety regulations the ones
that we've had from europe that meant
that planes were flying to ap could be
equally safe everywhere we're having to
redo
we haven't in the two minutes i've got
left you've got time to talk about
services or employment rights but when
people talk about european red type
that's often what they mean the fact
that you can have an employment contract
at all that comes from europe that equal
pay is underpinned by european law and
we know from the bcroft report where
this government is intending to go on
those things and indeed libertarians
such as daniel robert are often fond of
telling us about the dangers of these
overbearing states
but when the state itself is taking away
your rights who is it who's left to look
after you and one of the challenges here
is that the eu was giving you many more
protections than you might have realized
including on decent consumer rights
whether you could indeed just buy one
charger for your phone i don't know
about you but i'd rather carry around
one cable than many again something that
this government has decided not to pick
up
we haven't even talked about the shame
that is what is happening in northern
ireland as a result of playing fast and
loose with the good friday agreement
but if we got bryno has the eu changed
might be your question well surely we've
achieved that we've given them the short
sharp shock of walking out
well not really actually the eu has
worked together in ukraine and we have
been outside the room looking in the eu
again has started to work together on
refugees yet we are outside the room
looking in and deciding to deport people
to rwanda what have we got out of europe
then well fewer politicians we don't
have meps like daniel was we've got
those blue passports and the crown stamp
on your pint glass and some people have
made an awful lot of money out of it
crispin o'day a hedge fund manager who
lately contributed 650 000 pounds to the
pro-leave campaign made 220 million
pounds betting as the pound collapsed
post-europe and of course it is given
work for politicians like myself when
you've got 1500 pieces of legislation to
rewrite we can do that rather than deal
with the cost living crisis or climate
change or the social care crisis
so the answer is you must vote that we
were wrong to do brexit but also we now
need to fix it that's not about
rejoining that's not on the table and
it's not something i'm advocating but it
is about accepting responsibility and
your vote tonight for the point that
dominic and i make is to make people
like daniel and robert take
responsibility because daniel you quoted
the henry the v speech from the fifth
speech rather
when the campaign run the band of
brothers who fought for our freedom um
not least because that speech talks
about those who were not there should
hold their manhoods cheap when they
weren't fighting with you and i'll leave
you ladies and gentlemen think about
what manners they're talking about
because frankly the brexiteers got this
country by the short and curlies but as
mark queen margaret in henry vi taught
us wise men nurse sit and wail their
loss but cheerily seek how to redress
their harms so by voting with myself and
dominic tonight you are sending a
message to robert and to daniel to be a
little less of a hooray henry and much
more like maggie thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much thank you
stella um
uh
in a moment in a moment i'm going to
announce the results of the pre-vote um
before i do that can i just
try and stitch this panel together a
little bit um dominic grieve said that
the brexit vote had damaged
our sovereign power of influence i hope
i don't misquote you though i'm fairly
sure i got it right um on the opposite
side dan
said that the first foreign test was
the war in ukraine a suggestion that
really of a completely different view of
sovereignty and power dan
dominic said that because we were
outside the eu room on the ukraine we
had lost influence your suggestion is
that this this test had been passed can
i ask what what the test is that you see
and how it's been passed you would
expect dominic and me to disagree but
how about we allow either vladimir
zelinski or vladimir putin to to
determine this that they both see us
as respectively their greatest adversary
or their greatest supporter in the case
of ukraine if i made that there's one
thing that dominic absolutely got me on
in which i hold my hands up he's right i
totally failed to foresee the once in a
century pandemic
all of the
all of the predictions that uh the more
extreme remainers were making during the
campaign about backed up motorways in
kent and grounded flights and empty
shelves and people not being able to
travel all of that came true of course
for us as for every other country in the
world okay but i think that it is only
fair to say because we're hearing all
this stuff about we're slower growing
this year we are slower growing this
year because we did our growth spurt
last year because we came out of the
pandemic before uh
can i put a point to you you you said
and you you described your hesitation in
the vote you said you were surprised and
you were a professor i don't know a
french history of surprised by the
antagonism that britain um
faced from the eu and i i i i'm hesitant
to quote voltaire to you on the
execution of admiral being when he said
it was to encourage the others he of
course said it in french are you that
surprised that france and germany the
netherlands were going to be
such hard negotiators when we had
decided to leave
um what i thought was that they would
see that that it was in their long-term
interest to have a good relationship
with us as their largest customer the
most powerful european state their main
protector in fact
the main protector of european security
after the united states and that this
would they would take a long-term view
of this and accept a democratic decision
instead they tried to reverse that
decision or to aid those who are trying
to reverse it by making the negotiations
as difficult as possible and i would say
abusing their position over things like
ireland okay they were helped by the
poorly weakness of the theresa may
government
and also by the divisions within the
house of commons
after her disastrous election
semi-defeat
uh but yes i i i don't blame the eu for
being hard bargain bargainers i do
criticize them for being short-sighted
okay thank you very much um lastly
stella can i just ask you you you gave a
long list of rights that we may or may
not have given up that we may or may not
diverge from do you see any value since
we're discussing whether we were right
to brexit
to re-grounding those rights in the
british parliament and making a shorter
line of connection between
voter and law
what i see is a government that is
willing to use the henry viii powers
that whatever rights you have in the uk
parliament they will supersede them in a
small committee of 16 people for whom
they've stacked in favour of them so
actually i think never more has it been
important to have a third party standing
up and defending you and giving you
somewhere to seek
redress and
that puts me at odds with the
libertarians i find rather bizarre but
then i also never thought i'd be a red
arguing against red tape and yet this
government is bringing even more of it
as a result of brexit lovely thank you
very much indeed um so the pre-vote um
was as follows in favor of the nation 21
against 65 percent and the lucky
undecideds
are 14
let us go to questions there are
microphones going to be sort of passed
around the room um or run to you at
various points um
i have to say when i do these things
generally i rarely let the microphone
get into the hand of the audience
because they refuse to give it back
please do give it back i think we're
going to go first of all we have some
guests from mill hill school here
and i think
am i right josie
first of all
i would encourage everyone with thoughts
and questions to offer them but in the
form of questions a rising intonation at
the end of the sentence is the clue that
it's a question uh josie
when you're ready would both groups not
agree that it's still too early to know
whether we were right to brexit thank
you very much indeed i'd say a pretty
good question um
was it is it too early to decide whether
we were right to brexit um
from your side daniel
dominic i've always said nobody can tell
what the situation is going to be like
in 20 years time i said that at the time
of the referendum in 2016
long-term projections about a country's
future are very difficult
but the short to medium term projections
are i think absolutely startlingly clear
which is that we have taken a
significant economic hit
which i think will take us into a form
of stagflation i'm old enough to know
what it was like it's what took me into
politics as a conservative in the 1970s
when we were just joining the then eec
but actually the benefits of it were not
hadn't made themselves felt which really
came in particularly with margaret
thatcher's single market which we're now
out of
and i think
that the evidence is overwhelming
and what is most remarkable and i think
this really is clear is that daniel and
robert can both argue that you know if
you wait another five years things are
going to get better
but actually it is really hard to
identify a single concrete benefit that
has come to us from leaving the eu
either of a material character i cannot
think of one you know all right putting
the crown on we could put we could put a
crown on the pint glass without leaving
we could have had blue passports without
leaving if we chose to
we could have decided to do our own
thing on vaccines if we had been in the
eu
so
these things are non-existent we have
great freedom of action so i simply
cannot see what the benefits are at the
moment i accept you know in this
wonderful thing that daniel wrote in
2016 there were aspirations
which he plainly believed would be
sufficient to give us a much better
sense of national well-being and
economic security and wealth for
everybody
by going
but they just haven't happened and i
doubt they ever will okay daniel tell
you the other thing that i failed to
predict apart from the once in a century
pandemic
i could not have predicted
that the majority of mps in parliament
would pass an act
saying we will not permit britain to
leave the eu except on terms that
brussels likes
how do you expect the eu to respond when
they're given that opening and so all of
the criticisms we are getting about the
short-term difficulties about
particularly about the northern ireland
protocol those were products of the ben
act and and the politicians who voted
to take the power away from the
government and to give the eu that
extraordinary uh
which they couldn't get over a
negotiating advantage were featured
prominently uh stella and dominic so i
don't think that they get to make that
criticism daniel can i can i ask you to
address jose's yes there was an
excellent question
so that was that i thought it was it was
a very good question that's part of my
answer right the the now that there is a
majority uh in parliament it's a
different story so we we're dealing with
some of the the legacy of the terms on
which we left the other thing that is
just never debated that seems to have
completely disappeared from our
discourse is what's happening in the eu
and one of the oddest things is that the
eu has become this kind of symbol
against which people measure themselves
one way or the other the the flaws in
the european project the lack of
democracy this the the the sclerotic
wave of decision making the corruption
those things have completely disappeared
from our debate and so we have to
constantly ask ourselves what is it that
is the alter what would we be doing if
we'd stayed in i cannot think of any
example in the long term
of a country that has become poorer and
less successful as a result of becoming
more independent and i don't expect us
to be the first exception thank you very
much just hang on one second if you
would dominate for those um uh watching
from the comfort of their own homes or
in
far-flung way stations please do feel
free to ask questions online they do
come up here i will throw them at the
the panel at various points very briefly
if you would dominate
the ben act was passed because we
learned in august 2019 that the prime
minister unconstitutionally and he lied
about this was intending to provoke
parliament so as to enable him to carry
out a no deal brexit that people like
stella and myself considered would be so
disastrous for the country that it
couldn't be contemplated so that's why
the ben act was enacted if the prime
minister had behaved differently in july
2019 it wouldn't have been necessary
can i just pop one at you please either
of you really because you'll be aware
there is a very significant strain of
thought amongst those who voted leave
and who are very unhappy with the
process the parliamentary process
afterwards that people such as yourself
maybe not yourselves but that you went
out of your way actually to overturn the
referendum result did that cross your
minds did it cross the minds of your
colleagues stella what
i mean this goes back to josie's
question which is how long do you wait
after you've done something to review it
and see whether it's achieving what you
want to do as i said do we actually have
the brexit that we were promised and i i
think it's a bit difficult daniel to
lecture this audience about corruption
in the european union when you look at
what's currently going on in my
workplace right now in the conduct of
the prime minister
um
or
or indeed to offer the fact that a
pandemic happened as an excuse as to why
you couldn't have predicted this is the
point i think it was harod wilson who
said events dear boy wasn't it you know
that these things happen or maybe it's
macmillan apologies
i'm showing my age um the point is that
things happen to your country so the
question you must always ask yourself
and always be hungry for is is this the
in the best interests of our country
what you saw from the outside was a
parliament that was sclerotic not
because people weren't trying to act in
the best interest but because they
didn't know what people were trying to
achieve in the first place and my
question jose is how long do we wait
when we've seen the damage that is
already happening we're seeing the
businesses going out of places we're
seeing the loss of opportunity that's
coming i don't know whether you've ever
thought about studying abroad but i talk
to young people who've lost erasmus and
feel that they've lost something rather
special
and and they look at things like the
pandemic and think what else might
happen because we can never fully
predict the future we can recognize that
spending all of our time in the place i
liked called hogwarts gone wrong going
through 1500 pieces of paper only to
reconfirm the rules that we are already
abiding by is a colossal distraction
from the challenges that we need to face
in this country and i think we owe it to
your generation to use our time wisely i
am not convinced that this has been the
best use of people's time and that's why
i'm not here to call for us to rejoin
you might find that for surprising as
the chair that i moved for europe but i
am here to challenge people like dan who
on the one hand want us to go back into
the single market but on the other hand
want to find anybody else to blame
to take responsibility because you broke
it but we've all got to fix it for your
generation okay okay we'll leave it
there thank you very much thank you
stella um
of course you do robert of course you do
well when
when people start talking about what is
it that we've actually gained and what
are we going to gain in the future i and
when i hear dominic and stella talking
like that i'm it makes me think of some
red-faced colonel in the 1920s saying to
mrs pankhurst tell me one thing that
women have got from getting the vote
and the answer to that is they get
democracy they get a say in the way the
country's run and that is above all what
brexit brings
okay okay let's let's let's leave that
one there i'm going to come to the
audience but just to prove to the people
watching from beyond that your questions
really do matter i'm going to take one
from sarah who has written him a swift
answer from one of you i think on either
side would probably be best to both
sides do you think the staff shortages
we are experiencing now are made worse
by brexit dan
yes and they could be addressed i mean
brexit gave us power over immigration
how we exercise that power is up to us
and i am strongly in favor of
liberalizing so that we can admit people
who don't uh earn up to the threshold
for example
uh we have a huge shortage of qualified
chefs you can see lots of restaurants
that are not able to offer we should be
we should be uh bringing in qualified
chefs from bangladesh or whatever i mean
how can anyone argue against curry's
tasting better or whatever right so we
should be much more
we should be much more global in our
immigration policy okay okay thank you
very much
we find ourselves in agreement that the
shortage is due to brexit
the difference is that in the past there
was huge flexibility in the market
because people would come and go from
countries very close to ours to provide
those services
and now that's having to be replaced by
a ponderous bureaucratic system which in
many cases bringing people in who for a
variety of reasons will probably never
leave even if the economic circumstances
change
which on people's concerns for example
about population growth is a legitimate
one i cannot understand
how the system
which has been invented by daniel and
the government is in any way better than
the one we had previously and i also
make this prediction there are of course
controversial subjects on immigration
about whether people think it's
desirable or not but there's been a lot
of evidence over the years that it's a
thing which makes people very anxious i
think in many cases wrongly
but it's there and every government in
the last 40 years has had to grapple
with it i have to say that
my own prediction is if there is very
large scale immigration through the visa
system we will start to get exactly the
same concerns expressed over again okay
thank you very much indeed um gentleman
over in the corner sorry
we're just going to do one on each on
that side if we could just so we can get
through a number of questions gentlemen
in the corner would you give me your
name yes you sir would you give us your
name before you kick off ian gregory in
2019 the british people gave an
overwhelming majority to the great
charlatan boris johnson because the
alternative was dominic and stella
now they so disdained your points of
view stella could you explain
why the british people so distrusted the
eu
give three reasons why do you understand
that distrust of the eu can you explain
it or would you like to avoid that
question okay
um no i i i'm not sure
i'm not sure great charlatan is part of
the prime minister's official title um
so we should probably probably stick to
that if we can stella you seem to be
racing to give him
johnny
i think if the cap fits someone should
wear it um
i what you're talking about is not
unusual i i work in a profession where
nobody has any trust in what we do what
you're talking about is politicians and
i am somebody who's championed reform of
the european
union because frankly when you hear
these kind of conversations i i'm sorry
i'm mortified and i want to be explicit
i'm mortified on a platform we're
talking about importing people to make
curry when actually this is about
skills and treating people with respect
um
i don't i don't think it's me who sounds
like a red-faced retired colonel from
another century on this panel but i do
recognize what you're talking about
about politics and politicians that's
why many of us try for example to
promote things like citizens assemblies
because in other countries they've been
used because that well ian i'm trying to
address your question because my point
is it's not unique to the european union
for people to distrust public
institutions indeed it's in that
distrust that the project fear that came
from the leave campaign thrived there
were people from far away i speak as
somebody who was on the council of
europe for several years working with my
colleagues from different european
countries we were not unique in this
trusting the european union the question
as the question that churchill put is
you know this is democracy what is the
alternative and the reality is we are
following the rules that you are seeking
to be discharged from that european
commissioners etc are making so have you
actually had any of these benefits that
you were claimed to or you were simply
creating a time wasting exercise for
those of us in the house of commons okay
i'm dominic i'm job sorry your side has
had a lot of time at the moment let me
let me try and redress it a little bit
2019 election was won by the prime
minister for two reasons firstly uh
people looked at jeremy corbyn and
considered that he was a completely
unacceptable person to become prime
minister and i think they were very
understandable in those circumstances
even though he's genuine i think it
would have been disastrous and secondly
the prime minister lied to them the
fraud was to say that he had an
oven-ready deal that would deliver
brexit and which included the northern
ireland protocol and as i explained to
him in one of the last speeches i ever
made in the house of commons the
northern ireland protocol and the way he
was selling it was
false okay let's let's leave that there
look um you have praised what praise has
been made for the the youth of the
audience and i see a young lady right at
the edge there
first of all yes that's right you if you
could and then a gentleman here who's
patiently had his hand up so we'll go
from this young lady on the edge there
to the gentleman there young lady please
your name first if you would um
georgiana hi georgiana
um is there any realistic possibility
that we could actually
be richer in the future because we are
poorer now due to brexit okay thank you
very much let's get another question and
then i'll pop that if i may to the panel
uh sir you had your hand up there play
past the microphone yes thanks my name's
thomas mason i like johnny i'm a bbc
journalist so all my opinions have been
surgically removed but um i'll attempt
attempted observation
um one and it might be a first world
problem um but after brexit my favorite
choice of danish craft beer
subscription from from mckellar was no
longer possible uniquely to citizens of
the united kingdom and i believe now
having gone back to copenhagen i can get
it but it's an extra 35 pounds a month
yeah let's have a question um
when will there be less bureaucracy and
also are we still european because i was
still european
france at the channel tunnel on saturday
um the border guard said europeans this
way i said
we're still european
thank you sir thank you very much indeed
thank you very much always good to know
about your beer habits as well thank you
we appreciate that uh let's start with
um georgina's question if we could
robert if i could put this stupid which
was no not at all essentially she asks
um if though we may be poorer now and i
understand that is a matter of debate
and discussion um is it possible that we
can end up as a richer country as a
result of brexit going to the core of
our motion in fact whether we were right
to brexit are you confident i think you
spoke about
in the to the aei you spoke about brexit
being a gamble i think you used that
phrase are you confident that we will
end up richer even if we are undergoing
what dan has described as i think
transaction costs um at the current
period am i confident yeah i'm confident
that we can certainly end up richer
whether we will depends very much on the
government that we vote for
i agree with the with the the speakers
on the other side of the house that um
we've seen very little progress so far i
think this government has been
lamentable in its inability to take the
opportunities that brexit
opened up and i hope the future
government will be rather more effective
at doing so but the question is one that
dan referred to are you better off as an
independent democracy or are you better
off in the long run as part of a
declining and rather corrupt
multinational bloc and i think the
answer for me is definitely the first
it's a gamble on democracy and i'm
willing to take that gamble every time
thank you very much indeed um i don't
know which one of you would like to
address georgina's question i mean that
there must be there must be a
possibility in your mind that we end up
we may when nobody can say we can't just
looking further forward it's possible
the eu might collapse all sorts of
things could happen but i don't really
think so i think in the short term
there's two routes
daniel and robert both i think listening
to what roberts just said believe that
the uk should turn itself into the
singapore of the north east atlantic
this has been a dream
of a section of the conservatives
supporting uh
mps but it's a minority historically
that requires
societal changes of a really profound
character and 22 years in parliament
has made me realize a long time ago that
i don't believe this is sought or
desired by anything other than a tiny
minority and that's why
johnson is quite incapable of delivering
it and what has made some members of the
erg in his own party so angry with him
it just is never going to happen so the
alternative
is that we need to accept that we need
to be able to trade much more freely
than we're doing at the moment with our
nearest neighbors
and that then means starting to accept
some of the rules and if we accepted the
phyto-sanitary rules
then a lot of most of the northern
ireland protocol problem would be solved
and some of the things which are
upsetting people at the moment and
they're going to be even more upset when
they go away this summer and see some of
the consequences could be removed
but
those are the choices i mean ultimately
we could rejoin the eu although we will
have lost all the advantages that mrs
thatcher and others negotiated for us to
give us an exceptional position in it
which makes me so upset
so
it's not for tomorrow or indeed and i
share stella's view we have to be
realistic about where we are but the one
thing i'm absolutely convinced is
undeliverable is the vision which in a
sense was set out in daniel's article
which he wrote three days before the
general the referendum in 2016 and what
robert has just echoed now i don't
believe it's practical politics and i
don't think it'll ever happen thank you
very much indeed right um i've got
gentlemen right at the back there and a
gentleman who's been waiting very
patiently at the front here just to make
the microphone people write your name
first
and then i must confess i'm a reporter
at the express but i'm here for personal
terrible confession to have to make a
journalist
first of all i'd like to say that you
know miss degrees think about a small
minority a question remember yeah no no
i'll get 52 is a weird minority i must
say but on the wider point i think
there's an elephant in the room we're
really missing here is that there's a
country in eastern europe currently
subject to an invasion by by a power
that the eu has really failed to stand
up to in my opinion you've had the
germans for a long time again the
question jack yeah the question of
course of course but somebody else was
afforded the time to speak about
holidays so i think i'm a creditor
please please thank you so much so um i
think a little bit about that is that
the germans failed on swift whereas we
were quite hard line and we're offering
this support but berlin is now saying
that they're offering more support with
unlimited timeline i find it interesting
to suggest that the question's coming
sir that there's any suggestion that
britain hasn't stood up as an
independent self-governing nation and i
would like to know no i'd like to know
that why why a given example of how we
failed on the ukraine crisis okay thank
you now look i need to go back to this
question of whether we're still
europeans and then we'll come back if we
could to the ukraine um or to ukraine
forgive me definite article mistake lord
hanuman are we still europeans
some people will feel very european
others less so i speak french i speak
spanish i've lived in works all over
europe personally i've always felt much
closer to the commonwealth than to the
eu but that's a question for everyone to
me you know we don't want laws about
that i do want to say one thing though
that i think makes europe different
right we are currently engaged in trade
talks with the trans-pacific partnership
with mexico with the gcc with mercury
with others
none of them none of them is saying that
a condition of trade is that we have to
apply their standards behind our own
borders the only organization that tries
to do that is the european union and
that's why ultimately i think it is the
wrong model and that's why we will be
more prosperous long term as a global
economy relying on
reciprocity on mutual recognition of
standards than tying ourselves to the
regulatory model of the one bit of the
world that in proportionate terms is not
growing
thank you very much stella on this
question of our european nature but i
also i'm not doing my job as a local mp
i don't suggest you sir that you can
find much better craft breweries in
walthamstow i mean goodness me northeast
london has to have something to offer to
itself um jack your question from the
express
reflects the the central challenge here
is the idea that it must either always
be either the uk or the eu
why can't we collaborate with i mean
that's where daniel and i agree daniel
has written about the importance of
collaboration with other nations
absolutely we've wanted to all act as
one to challenge peter and i sit here as
the only person on this panel who has
actually been banned from russia so jack
i think i know a little bit about
standing up oh and dominic to be fair
dominic has um as well
it's not about whether one is belarus
nothing really i
listen as i said before it's a pity ban
but it's something
my point jack is that absolutely we
should be challenging the hungarians we
should be challenging the germans do you
think we are more likely and more
capable of doing that inside the room in
those negotiations sitting around that
table fighting our corners standing up
for what we believe is right rather than
outside you genuinely believe we have
more influence shouting out well you're
showing that yourself right now with
your heckling and that may be the
challenge here it's not always about us
versus the european union absolutely
there are things we want to change about
the european union whether we're inside
or outside it i'd say as somebody who
does a lot of work on refugee rights
i've long been concerned about how the
european union approaches refugees i've
long been concerned about how the
express approaches refugees but
i recognize and i went to the council of
europe and i've stood up in parliament
to have that debate because i'm not
frightened to fight for what i believe
in why are you so frightened for britain
being in the room fighting for its
values and challenging the germans
directly rather than having to do it in
bilaterals outside the room what a waste
of time and effort and energy that only
can help putin actually if we want to
tackle putin we do speak as one and we
push the germans and the hungarians to
go further faster rather than pulling
our punches which is what happens when
you're not in the room that's always
been the challenge with this and it's
the same with dan's point i can't let
him get away very briefly the idea that
there isn't something to fight for right
now the european union is looking at
some stats some basic standards mean
that whether you're buying something you
would know whether it was tat now i
don't know about you ladies and
gentlemen i buy an awful lot of tap i'd
quite like to know whether the things
i'm buying are durable the european
union is setting some common consumer
rights and our government has to make a
choice about whether it's going to give
you that information and i'd say in a
cost-living crisis knowing whether what
you're buying is tap and will fall apart
in five minutes or actually it's worth
investing it's quite an important thing
to do not everything the european union
doing is is bad not everything the uk
does is good what we need is some
political reality jack rather than some
hot air and i'd say the express has a
role to play in that too okay no i'm
gonna i think stella has
made yourself opinions very very clear
we've got a gentleman right in the front
here thank you very much for your
patience and thank you for all your
questions and do send them in from home
sir thank you
my name is john i'll be trying to be
very very quick i have a question from
mr grieve and miss creasy um ursula von
de la and mario draghi and emmanuel
macron have all spoken very recently
about their desire for the eu to move
towards qualified majority voting to
determine member states foreign and
security policies that implies that most
decisions about the most fundamental
issues for example policies towards our
relations with the united states
the involvement in ukraine and russia
would be made by politicians completely
removed and unaccountable
no democratic accountability to national
electorates you both either are or have
been democratically elected national
politicians how could that ever be an
acceptable outcome to you okay let's
have one
one of you answer
on this issue um
so our ability to influence or indeed
block because we could that measure has
gone
and this is this is precisely the point
we will find that the eu takes decisions
which actually do have quite profound
effect on us even out of it without our
input
the eu isn't a perfect organization i
mean i entirely agree with so many of
the criticisms made of it
rather bizarrely i spent most of my
career being described as a euro skeptic
but i have to say to you by leaving it
we have made a colossal error because
what it does has a direct bearing on us
and our influence and ability to work
inside it to achieve our national goals
and help them achieve the goals that we
think are desirable for them as well has
completely gone
so there's no point in raising this
issue they will do what they want i
suspect it won't go through for a whole
variety of reasons but because actually
other member states also have differing
views from the
french but the simple fact is our
influence there and our ability to
manage that is gone okay thank you very
much let's take a question on online and
this probably drills down to a lot of
people's opinions or feelings about the
issue and it's very simple from
anonymous could we have evidence in
figures of the benefits of brexit does
this go back
um
my proposals to this question of whether
it's too early or it's too confused
because of the issue of the pandemic dan
do you do do you feel the
the the the exit love in the figures
well we heard a lot of the figures uh in
robert's speech the the difference
between what was predicted and what has
actually happened we were the fastest
growing european economy last year
because we came out of the uh the
lockdown earlier we are predicted to be
19th out of 20 on these this year
yes so
okay i know that's an important point
right if if
if everyone falls back to from 190 and
then last year i go
from 90 to 100 and this year you catch
up i am better off right i mean it's
there's no point in grabbing the the
snapshot and uh and pretending do you
think there are figures that say
definitively we're on the right path or
is it too early
to make an obvious point
robert was correct that it's up to us
brexit on its own
doesn't add all subtractive farthing
what it does is it removes constraints
and it allows us to make different
choices and which choices we make
will determine how prosperous we are so
we could we could have gone the kobe
needs to roof and ended up like
venezuela we could end up like singapore
we could end up somewhere in between the
two but do you know what i would rather
live in a country where that is
democratically decided even if i'm
sometimes on the losing side of the vote
then live in a policy where those
decisions are made for me and imposed
without democratic consent okay let me
put the question if i made
the opposition i don't know who wishes
to pick up out of the two of you this
question of figures definitive figures
on the benefits of brexit you look as if
you feel a bit too early don't worry i'm
sorry you need to decide between
yourselves
i mean i i just think
i'm perplexed robert because i think if
someone came to you as an academic where
they hadn't evidenced the basis for
their claims
you would want to see the basis for
their claims the the information that
i've presented in my presentation came
from uk in the changing europe which is
an independent think tank at the kings
at king's university from the office of
budget responsibility again another
independent body set up by government to
hold politicians like myself to account
so that the facts weren't challenged it
was opinions that were in contention um
i the the data is very very clear we
have taken an economic hit as a result
of brexit our imports and our exports
have been affected daniel i love the
fact that you play fast and loose with
the time frames that you looked at when
you look about 2016 we hadn't left the
european union then we sank so low then
the figures hang on
down down hang on please sorry stella i
know fact facts aren't up for debate but
discussion is and i welcome the fact
that you are being honest about that
that you were looking at different time
frames but you cannot move away from
what the officer budget responsibility
uk are changing europe
the lse data has shown us it's the lse
that's been looking at the impact of
inflation and directly segregating it to
prove that leaving the european union
has made the cost of food more expensive
and as somebody who has the constituency
with the ninth highest level of child
poverty and has people who aren't
choosing between heating or eating
because they can't afford to do either i
am desperately concerned about that and
desperately concerned about the impact
of brexit it's not the only thing but it
is a big thing and everything you are
talking about
is talking about bringing more
complexity more risk of those factors
getting worse and i guess the question
for all of us is how much pain do you
expect us to go through before those
sunlit uplands okay um
thank you uh robert you were you were
criticized there by stella if you'd like
to respond on that point about figures
thank you
um
it's strange to blame rising prices on
brexit when prices in the eu are rising
faster than our prices
labor shortages in the eu are at least
as bad as our
labor shortages and they're due not to
brexit but to the long-term effects of
the curb i think inflation is is
generally higher in britain than it is
in most food prices food food prices
food prices forgive me forgive me that
forgive me uh and industrial goods
prices inflation is also lower i think
now um perhaps i could make an offer or
a challenge to to stellar
i don't know whether um whether
intelligence squared has a website i
suppose it must do i will give all the
sources of all the figures that i've
quoted and perhaps she could do the same
okay okay we're going to leave it there
on the questions and forgive me i know
there were lots of people who didn't get
a chance both at home and wherever you
are uh far flung um or in the hall and
apologies for that thank you to all of
our panelists for
giving um their responses are candid and
clear it's time for a closing statement
and uh you only have one minute i'm
afraid and that will be strict um with
the tapping of the glass there is no
warning tap this time round stella
creasy would you like to start oh sorry
dominic would you like to stop you'll
take it now dominic
we've plainly made a major error
is the country in a better condition
today than it was in 2016
that's that seems to me the only way you
can answer this question at the moment
of course you can look to potential
future
but um unless you're going to project a
long way ahead and take big gambles
rationally
when you see where the uk was in june
2016 when we went into that referendum
and it took place you saw that in fact
we had the fastest growing economy in
europe you saw we had more investment
than any other european country and
actually we were beginning to perform
economically in a way that was even
challenging
german performance
and you look where we are now
our ability to provide the well-being of
our citizens has been adversely affected
in a major way
and on top of that our global influence
has been diminished
and i listened to all these things about
sovereignty but i have to say to you
absolute sovereignty does not exist
sovereignty is about making choices
about who you cooperate with we've made
a choice to stop cooperating and we're
paying the price for it and it's the
cooperation with our nearest neighbors
thank you very much indeed um i don't
know which of you two would like to go
first uh robert are you happy to go
first okay thanks i tried to talk about
the eu and about democracy and the other
side answers by talking about having one
sort of telephone cable and arguing
about statistics
we were not only the fastest growing
economy in europe in 2016 we've been the
fastest growing economy in europe from
the year 2000 to the year 2021.
um
brexit didn't make any difference about
that but my standard my stand on this is
not about one years or two years or
three years economic growth figures but
about the long-term future of the
country as a democratic nation and that
i think is what we voted for in 2016
what some people try to prevent
and what i hope we shall have a
government which will eventually carry
out
thank you very much indeed robert that's
excellent thank you and dominic if you
would
oh i'm so sorry forgive me i've got
confused with the bright lights stella
of course thank you
everybody needs a bogeyman in life
someone to blame when things get tough
the european union has been britain's
bogeyman for failing to deal with the
endemic challenges we've had in our
country for far too long and just as
kaiser jose reveals themselves at the
end of the usual suspects so you also
have an opportunity here to be very
clear that you won't be hoodwinked
you've seen the lorry parks you've seen
the price rises you've seen the people
struggling to get visas you've seen the
division in our country and yes you've
seen the challenges with the multiple
charging cables for your phones the
questions are what are we going to do
about it
i didn't come into politics to sit and
repeat myself i know that might sound
surprising and yet what we are doing in
parliament is repeating the same piece
of legislation because ultimately when
it comes down to a union no union is
perfect you get out of it what you put
into it we walked away from the european
union sir we walked away from our
opportunity to block the things that we
didn't like now it's time we take
responsibility for sorting out the
problems that we have created and
sorting out the challenges that our
country have and i would much rather
spend my time talking about those and
making things better for my constituents
whether the european union were in it or
out of it but do i think we could have
done that more easily in the european
union of course thank you very much
indeed and to give us our final summary
uh dan johnny just very quickly to
answer your question about inflation i
just looked up the ons figures for may
uk inflation was six point seven percent
eurozone inflation was seven point seven
percent eu inflation overall was eight
point nine percent so there's thank you
very much
that is always missed out
what about the eu and what's happening
there i am convinced that if david
cameron had come back with a single
retrieval of power with one concession
he would have won the referendum because
he would have been able to refute the
idea of a one-way street of a ratchet
he'd been able to say look powers can
come down it's not always being
centralized
ponder what the what it means that the
eu was readier to lose its second
financial contributor
than to allow any devolution of power
from brussels to the national level
and since the result in the uk
some have reacted in brussels with anger
some with scorn some with disbelief no
one no one has said oh i wonder why they
voted leave
i wonder whether whether anyone else
might have doubts i wonder whether we
might have played that differently on
the contrary they've pushed ahead as we
were hearing from john over here with
more integration particularly in the
fiscal and military fields and so
staying in the eu was never a status quo
option
staying in the eu means being
incorporated into an ever closer policy
evolving all of the attributes and
trappings of nationhood i would rather
live in a free democracy than in a
multinational empire
thank you very much indeed thanks dan
thank you
um
it is time to vote and to see if there
is a point of order here that if daniel
has been able to provide figures let us
provide the evidence that when you strip
out the impact of the energy costs
inflation in the uk is 1.6 higher than
germany three percentage points higher
than france and more than three percent
points higher than italy indeed uk core
inflation is catching up with core
inflation in the us despite the us
having a much greater fiscal stimulus
that is brexit we're going to
we will we will have we will have to
leave the city so i need what i what i
would like you to do however is to now
vote um uh and we'll see if anyone has
had their mind changed or swayed by what
you have heard tonight that whilst you
are voting um i'd quite like just to
pick up a couple of points if i could
stella
um you spoke about
a bogeyman um that enabled politicians
to hide behind it is there anything is
there any advantage do you think in
there no longer being a bogeyman for
westminster politicians to hide behind
unable to say that's europe's fault and
to take responsibility
is there any involvement
is there any disadvantage in politicians
actually taking responsibility most the
problems that you're talking about it's
like the issues around
uh refugees and immigration the problem
wasn't immigration the problem was
politicians not being honest with you
about what the challenges were and how
to make the system work and now we're
all fearing the consequence for it
whether in the nhs or indeed the
horrific way that we're now responding
to people coming from
uh overseas and being sent to rwanda i
i'm in favor of politicians being more
transparent and i think fungus of
bogeyman rather gets in the way of that
okay thank you very much and dan may i
ask you i mean
bearing in mind the extraordinary number
of visas that were issued um in the last
chunk of statistics that came out what
last week more than a million visas
whatever your opinion do you not think
that many of those who voted for brexit
will have been surprised and to some
degree betrayed by
the overall figure notwithstanding your
discussion of control i have to say
there's no evidence of that either in
the opinion polls or in conversations i
have a rule of thumb
a heuristic if you will that if anyone
if any british person tells you that the
brexit vote was all about immigration
you are talking to someone who voted
remain
no leaver thinks that it was about
immigration we know that it was about
democracy
okay well um
i have to say
from my own experience which was 10
weeks of travel around the united
kingdom discussing this with everyone
you could possibly imagine uh
immigration played a large part in a
significant number of people's decisions
um but that is only how you voted johnny
no no no that's that's entirely unfair
and a presumption um however the good
news is uh we do have the results in um
i have two sets of results that say
first vote results on my screen so i'm
going to take a mad guess and say the
one that is slightly varied ah exchange
to final thank you very much indeed um
we have um a swing in fact the
undecideds have plummeted from 14 down
to 2
those against the motion are at 67 they
were at 65 percent and those for the
motion are now 31 they were at 21 so you
can see which way the debate has gone
[Applause]
and
it really only
leaves me to say thank you for coming
thank you very much for watching at home
as well but thank you to our wonderful
family thank you so much thank you very
much that's a great pleasure really was
thank you
robert thank you so much it's a real
pleasure to be here with you